will iraq slide into civil strife
supporters of powerful leader mukhtar
assad are still occupying the parliament
they're refusing to leave until their
demands are met
but what if they aren't and what role
does iran play in iraqi politics
this is inside story
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum protesters have once again
taken over iraq's parliament in a show
of support for influential shia leader
muqtada
on saturday thousands of people stormed
the building in baghdad for the second
time in a week they vowed to stay put
until their demands are met escalating a
political standoff at least 125 people
were injured southern supporters reject
the nomination of muhammad shaya as
sudani as prime minister it's been 10
months since the elections but a
deadlock remains over the formation of a
new government
reports from baghdad
once again supporters of shia cleric
mokta dasadar occupy iraq's parliament
but this time they vow to stay put until
their demands are met
we reject corruption and corrupt
politicians sudan is a tool in the hands
of foreign powers he and his colleagues
work against iraq he won't do anything
for our benefit
we won't leave until we kick those
corrupt politicians out of iraq
a pro-iranian bloc called the
coordination framework has nominated
muhammad a sudani for prime minister
these protesters have linked him to
former premier nuri al-maliki
despite calls for calm by many officials
including sadhu who instructed his
supporters to pray from violence
the protesters were far from peaceful
the health ministry has confirmed dozens
of people including soldiers were
injured
when police fired tear gas at the crowd
[Music]
everyone shares the responsibility
political parties the political elite
social forces and influential figures we
have to say it to everyone and everyone
must act wisely with iraq in mind in
order not to lose again
saturday's parliamentary session had
been dedicated to electing a new
president
followed by the naming of a prime
minister
who would then form a new government
all that is now on hold
giving rival politicians a chance to
meet
but these protesters are worried that
mps could hold an unannounced session
to approve sudany
so now they're in for the long haul
so who is muktada
the founder of a popular shia movement
his block won 74 seats in october's
elections making it the largest faction
in parliament
but last month suther ordered all 74 mps
to resign because of a failure to form a
government
sullar was the leader of a powerful
militia the mahdi army which was founded
in 2003 in response to the u.s invasion
he is a populist who enjoys strong
support among poorer shia communities
sadler opposes the nomination of
muhammad
for prime minister saying he is too
close to tehran
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in doha doing
non-resident fellow at the arab center
washington dc in baghdad martin ashamari
is a research fellow at harvard kennedy
schools middle east initiative and in
tehran hamid musavi a professor of
political science at the university of
tehran a warm welcome to you all and
thanks so much for joining us today on
inside story marcin let me start with
you today uh first i want to ask you who
exactly are these protesters are the
protesters that are currently engaged in
this sit-in in parliament the ones who
are occupying parliament are they only
supporters of mukhtar al-sadr and is
what they are seeking representative of
what other iraqis want
this is a very important question
because i think it's very relevant to
how impactful these protests are and how
much effect they'll have on iraq going
forward to answer your question
predominantly they are the followers of
musta
but there are other iraqis involved in
these protests as well and we might
expect more to join later on but the
vast majority of them are sudharists
um but their their demands do resonate
to some degree with the rest of
the rest of the country and other iraqis
for example where they resonate most
strongly is in this call for ending
corruption and bringing those who are
corrupt to accountability where they may
be less resonant with iraqis is their
demands for another set of early
elections um for an interim government
until that happens and perhaps even for
the rewriting of the constitution so in
some ways they speak to the majority of
iraqis but in other ways
their demands particularly for early
elections might actually anger the
public more than
more than bring them together
zedon is there any kind of a solution
that can be reached to get beyond this
current political stalemate um and also
how much is the the rivalry between
former prime minister nuriyar malki and
mukhtar assad driving all of this
well firstly the solution could be uh
between the coordination framework and
the soldiers movement but that seems to
be very difficult for the past few
months due to
rivalries and very old rivalries as you
mentioned the one between former prime
minister nouri maliki and the mukhtar
sagar the leader of the sadhus movement
however maliki's potential for any
candidacy towards the prime minister
role has been very limited or almost
abolished after the leak audio where he
criticized his very own
allies within the coordination framework
who have been for months negotiating
with saddar to keep or maintain
al-maliki within the coordination
framework so the crisis here has not
only become a crisis or a dispute
between two different parties but it has
also led into internal disputes within
the very same uh parties themselves such
as the coordination framework which is
also why we're probably not
noticing or witnessing any strong
political or even
on-ground response from the coordination
framework due to the schism or in the or
the fragmentation
that took place after the leaks the the
suggest movement or the suggest leader
is currently focusing on how to create
obstacles for the coordination framework
ensuring that it won't take them a
shorter time or an easier time to form a
government which he failed to do for the
past 10 months similar to the obstacles
they presented to his
coalition with takadom and kdp
mohammed how is the iranian government
viewing
what is playing out in in iraq right now
and and what is iran's position when it
comes to what's happening
i think iran does not want to unrest in
iraq i don't think it serves iran's
interest i don't think it serves iraq's
interest as well
iran's position is that all factions in
iraq should respect the democratic
process
failed to form a coalition government
and i think he should now provide an
opportunity for the opposition to do
to attempt to form a coalition
government uh while i think many people
support the goals of the protesters i
don't think sit-ins and protests will
actually achieve the goals they are
looking for
now i know that there are a lot of
discussions among the protesters about
interference about
iran interfering in iraq's affairs
in reality i think this is mostly a
rivalry between
domestic uh
iraqi groups and domestic iraqi parties
iran does enjoy
uh
some
actual a lot of not some but maybe
considerable influence in iraq but that
doesn't mean that iran is interfering
in iraqi affairs so i i think ultimately
this is mostly a rivalry between
domestic political groups in iraq
marcine you may have heard ze doon a
moment ago talk about
fragmentations going on in in political
blocks right now in iraq i want to ask
you from your vantage point uh do you
believe that mukhtar al-sadr's rivals in
the pro-iran coordination framework
block do you believe that they're
showing signs of any internal divisions
i'm asking that because you know it's
been reported on the one hand that there
are some leaders in that block that that
want to see
dialogue go forth and there are other
leaders within that block that would
like to see counter demonstrations
yeah let's go back actually a few weeks
back to when um
was still invested in the political
process and in creating a government and
at that time something that was very
telling was that in his pursuit of a
majority and opposition government he
actually did reach out to certain
segments of the coordination framework
namely almost everyone but former prime
minister nuril maliki in order to get
them on his side and to collaborate with
them and to marginalize maliki in the
process
so
what we see here is their unwillingness
to step away from the coordination
framework and to form an alliance with
sadhara back then which actually speaks
to the remarkable
[Music]
connectedness and the remarkable degree
of uh unitedness that they're showing at
this point this i don't think is really
based on any ideology but more of a
calculation that
united they are
a threat or they are immensely powerful
when put up against mukhter sudder but
if they go to his side then it weakens
them individually so i think that's a
calculus that they made back when the
offer was even more
[Music]
more attractive than it is right now
and i think right now we do see
different kinds of messages from
different leaders in the coordination
framework but they don't seem to be
messages that are countervailing
messages in any way so mostly they have
been calling for the production of
public property uh for dialogue and for
really doing things within the outlines
of um
of of the law and of procedures that are
enshrined in the state
so they they do represent a somewhat
united front and we can't really expect
them to be more united than this because
they are a group of very powerful
individuals some with paramilitary
groups who have been accustomed to being
independently strong actors so there
it's a multi-polar kind of setup the
coordination framework rather than a
hegemonic or a unipolar one with maliki
at the top
zedon is it any surprise to you that
mukhtar al-sadr's supporters were able
to enter parliament and that they are
able to stay there now and from your
perspective how long might we see
parliament occupied by these protesters
not at all unfortunately the reality in
iraq is that most of these political
parties with armed wings as mentioned by
marcin are people that are able to to
infiltrate and bypass many security
military checkpoints and this is a very
easy one comparing them to the october
2019
protest movement when protesters tried
to access a few bridges that would lead
them to tahrir square which is a public
square and they were met with political
violence either
from the political parties that are
currently in dispute today or from their
armed wings or from a third
hidden party as the governmental media
likes to refer to them to push away or
hide away the accusation from the
political parties that are involved in
assassinating these protesters
unfortunately the the political parties
and disputes or blocs which is the
coordination framework and the soldiers
movement equally are able uh to to
bypass any military checkpoint and and
face any uh
governmental premises and enter any
governmental building without facing the
similar consequences that were faced by
the peaceful protesters
hamad how did the relationship between
muhammad get so bad what went wrong
well actually
has spent considerable time in iran
especially in the city of bomb in the
past two decades he has repeatedly
come to iran he even met iran's supreme
leader numerous times uh in the past
decade uh it's it's very difficult to
tell exactly what went wrong uh one
theory is that murtada al-sajad is a
person who
he changes his mind very frequently
another reason perhaps can be that he
had a
a quite good relationship with qasem
soleimani
after his death perhaps that's not
existing anymore
but ultimately i think he's a person
who's uh
he's very neurotic and he seems to be
changing his mind very frequently but in
the past year i think relations between
iran and
al-sadr have become very bad
marcin um
how involved is iran right now
in in iraq
obviously they've been involved in iraq
for a long time um but is it a more
hands-off approach at the moment or is
there a lot of pressure being brought to
bear on iraq by iran right now
well when government formation was still
underway in the sense that
there was invested in it there was
iranian involvement in the sense of
diplomatic
pressure and presence in order to get
the various groups in iraq to come to an
agreement
simply because of how long it was taking
iran will always have influence to some
degree in iraq but
this particular government formation
cycle i think foreign intervention in
iraqi politics has been less than usual
not non-existent what is interesting
though is basically mukta sadhar's bid
to form a majority government with his
kurdish and
sunni allies was something that was
supported by a lot of arab countries
in in the region and we see that their
intervention in trying to push this
through has failed so there are there
are various foreign actors who are
invested in the outcome of iraq's
election and government formation
they do how concerned are you right now
that that iraq could slide into real
civil strife i mean what are the chances
this could get much worse and that
violence could play out in the days or
months ahead
well a lot of the armed wings
or former armed wings that belong to a
lot of the political parties whether it
be the soldiers movement or the ones
within the coordination framework do
have a history of an armed conflict
particularly when we talk about the the
traditional the historical
rivalry
it existed
since 2006 uh some of the the the
political uh parties within the
coordination framework splitted out of
the soldiers movement in the early
stages of the u.s invasion so there is a
history of civil strife however the
possibility might be a bit lower than in
the early stages of the u.s invasion
there are more platforms of dialogue
there are more political parties and
political individuals that are very
powerful in today's iraq that would
rather continue or take this forward in
a peaceful dialogue because iraq is
going through since october 2019 protest
movement the political system or the
political class of post 2003 iraq is
going through a very drastic
transitionary period where it is
determined whether this political system
will survive whether this ethnic ethnic
sectarian political system will survive
it has been questioned by the rising
political consciousness of the youth of
the civil society the international
community is also realizing the alarming
effects of the failures of this
political class towards education public
goods public services and the
sovereignty of the iraqi borders
including
the the the the the alarming
impacts on iraqi sovereignty from
equally from different regional power
players including iran
so
this is certainly an issue that will be
considered in the long term however
there will be more platforms of dialogue
that could ensure that this crisis is
more political than it really relates to
the daily lives of wood and iraqi
citizens sure the suggest movement does
by the hearts and minds of so many
people across the spectrum when it comes
to nationalism and reform but in reality
as we noticed in the lowest voter
turnout since uh the the establishment
of the current iraqi democratic system
it proves that most iraqis do not
affiliate themselves with these
political parties and they do not
affiliate with themselves with this
political system and they hope to see a
different political system as they do
it's interesting you're bringing up
these mass protests that happened in
2019 i was in baghdad covered
covered many of those protests in
october and november of that year in
2019
and and i encountered so many members of
these youth protesters who said they had
no faith in the government whatsoever
they wanted a complete overhaul of the
political system i'm curious to get your
perspective if you think that there is a
chance that we might see mass protests
again
like what we saw in 2019
there is
a very big possibility that people
witnessed uh similar mass protests
however unfortunately the the
the focus or the the momentum of the
protest movement has lowered
due to a lot of distractions that
dragged away the attention from the
protest movement and it also created a
lot of
pessimism amongst the iraqi youth
as you probably recall uh right after
the the like shortly after the the the
breakout of the october 2019 protest
movement we witnessed a lot of uh
destabilizing events that took place
whether it was uh the assassination of
basum suleimani whether it was the
political violence attempts committed by
the armed wings of the political parties
within the iraqi government towards the
peaceful protesters
or the political failures and ensuring
to create a caretaker government that
would be different from the similar
faces or from the similar political
parties and interest groups that the
people
initially revolted against from the
first place so this might be just
another event or incident or another
series of incidents that will distract
the people uh pull the people away from
giving them hope that the change is
possible by only protesting however
currently it's in the it's in the it's
the ball is in the court of the
political parties that are trying in one
way or another to save this political
system however if you have players such
as
who would like to redefine the political
system under his own terms for
objectives that he had planned a very
long time ago mohammed what steps do you
think we'll see iran take if if what is
happening now in iraq escalates and if
it causes serious instability
well i think this is happening at a very
sensitive time for iran i don't think
iran wants this unrest to continue iran
is currently engaged in very sensitive
negotiations on its nuclear issue with
the united states it's also engaged in
negotiations with saudi arabia where
iraq is actually hosting these
negotiations so i think these unrest are
actually happening at a very bad time
for iran and i think iran wants these
unrest to end as soon as possible and
nevertheless i don't think iran
has the necessary influence and the
necessary tools to end this
uh i think uh iran will try to negotiate
and facilitate negotiation between the
two sides but as i said before i think
the uh relationship between iran and
murtada al-sadr has deteriorated
in the past year uh gawani which is the
new
head of the puts force of iran
uh he doesn't enjoy the same kind of
relationship that sulaimani enjoyed with
mukhta al-sadr so i think ultimately
iran has to
engage with some sort of negotiation
with mukhta al-sadr to fix the situation
uh marcin um briefly i want to ask you
about
how bad is the situation currently for
ordinary iraqi citizens i mean we're
talking about a political stalemate
we're talking about a political crisis
but how is all this impacting
citizens in a country where there is
such high unemployment where they have
not been able to approve a budget where
there's joblessness where people are so
frustrated how bad are things getting
for normal everyday average iraqis
the last 10 months have honestly been
excruciating for the average iraqi
because of the lack of government and as
you said the lack of a budget there
hasn't really been any room to
implement any improvements in terms of
public services or to be able to
provide for employment through private
sector and sadly through public sector
as well which is unadvisable but iraqis
do look towards that um so
everyday citizens are quite fed up with
the impasse it has been the longest
impasse in iraq's close 2003 history so
it is making life really difficult for
everyone particularly as the climate
crisis has hit iraq really hard with
continuous sandstorms um occurring on a
several times a month that have made
everyday life very very difficult um
when it comes to this actual protest
movement and its effect on everyday life
to be honest its effect on traffic and
on the streets in baghdad hasn't been
very noticeable um there's been less
people outside of their homes than usual
but the city
the high alert in the city is really
is really contained to the areas around
the international zone
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave our
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests zaidun al-kinani marcina
mari and mohammed musavi
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammadan zoom in the whole team here
bye for now
you